[Music]
joe
i feel like you and then me and case
probably
are the ones that have moved the most
recent
yes you guys haven't moved right you
guys haven't moved no not in like
two years now yeah oh yeah so i moved a
month ago
that's pretty recent that's really
recent oh yeah you're the most recent oh
you guys
was in march so it's been a long time
but it feels like it hasn't been that
long because it's been the pandemic this
whole time which feels weird feels like
one month
yeah but anyway so would you say that
moving
is the most stressful
like life event nah i liked it
i liked it a lot because i was like i
couldn't wait to get the hell out of
that house
and then i was like the process of
moving though
i think i moved in two days she's
looking for you to say it sucks
no you could say if it's tight or not i
just want you to
specify like just to understand my
question which is
the the process of moving not the fact
that you had moved to a different place
because it's always an upgrade how did
you feel did you have movers
yeah i think i would have been even more
stressed out
or i would have been less stressed out
if i didn't go
camping the other day and i came home
and i had to move
yeah that was stressful because i i was
packing
everything and then the movers they were
late
they were supposed to come at noon and
they didn't come until six
and i was supposed to be out that day
that's a six-hour difference
yeah that's incredibly stressful yeah i
guess i was
well i don't really get stressed out
because my friends were there and we had
a lot of fun moving
so it just depends on who you are i
guess and i know little [ __ ]
right so i don't want a t-shirt of that
i know little [ __ ] it depends who you
are i know a little bit
yeah i just want a t-shirt that just
says that and then right there it's just
joe joe but it's like it's got to be
like contextually associated with like
moving out
you know what i mean it's not even just
like uh i know the [ __ ]
even when the movie just comes six hours
later you know what i mean
is [ __ ] crazy yeah they're late six
hours
yeah they're russian i'm sorry we have
overbooking and then staff you know
because pandemic i didn't have enough
stuff always russian
yeah what's the deal with ukrainian and
russian
movers no we are terribly sorry we give
you borscht
yes you like borscht we give you caviar
beat soup please and i was like ah
[ __ ] it and i was like um i wanted to go
to russia
i was talking about russia with them and
they're like yes beautiful city russia
moscow is very beautiful saint
petersburg very beautiful
that's what they told me oh that's good
that's a good hot tip yeah and i was
like who
now like move yeah put that on yeah
right so okay joe would you
classify um starting your first job
ever being more stressful or less
stressful than moving
starting my first job ever um
yeah my first job was pretty stressful
but then after an hour into it i was
like this is [ __ ] easy people get
paid for this [ __ ]
so it was the idea oh you know where i
think i get stressed out
before things happen more than it
actually happening
because the move was stressful like and
all these problems happened
but maybe i procrastinate because i
don't like to plan because the planning
stresses me out
so i really just [ __ ] plow through
whatever i got to in one day
so same with work like getting the
interview
getting the job that process is so
[ __ ] stressful
but when i'm actually working i'm like
oh this is so easy
why did i stress so hard what was your
first job aside from all the illegal
things i did
my first real job was target i was a
card technician i was a cart technician
and i took that job seriously
[Laughter]
what was this it's not funny it's an
honest living
do they call them cart corrals is that
correct is that accurate
i don't know why i was asking them i was
like why is it called cart technician
when we don't work on the carts and we
just collect them and put them away
and they said don't make fun of my job
dude what the [ __ ]
i'm your manager for some reason i can
imagine like young joe
just like dancing as he's just
collecting these cards together
and pushing yeah it was played with back
playing in the background yeah i imagine
being the dude that's like pushing stuff
but his butt cracks like hanging out the
top
he's like joe you gotta pull up your
pants i was like i was around 19.
yeah yeah my first job nice okay well
the reason why i ask you all these
questions joe is because
there was this survey that found
that the people surveyed they said that
moving
was more stressful than breaking
up or going through a divorce more
stressful than getting married more
stressful than having children
more stressful than starting your first
job ever entering a new career
industry sending a child off to college
starting college
dating someone new getting a pet all
those things
um are less stressful than moving you
know why
because they're little [ __ ] that's
why that's what i'm talking about so
sick dude
i i had to move cross country when i was
a kid and that was a [ __ ] nightmare
because but you were a kid though well
right but but for my family though
because they were moving from virginia
to california
via u-haul like driving the whole time
with two cars and pets and [ __ ] we
had cats
we had a dog it was like wild that's
tight it's a new age mode
uh oregon trail yeah dude we had fish
we had fish for some reason we kept the
fish and when and it was during a
blizzard that we were moving
so by the time we got to california our
fish were just an ice block
yeah they got frozen and the fish
completely froze them yeah you didn't
even keep them like inside of the car
with you no we did but we we
tried to insulate it and [ __ ] but you
know it was like
it got way colder than mine than anyone
thought that it would
because this blizzard happened at the
same time how long was that trip though
it was like it was like nine days it was
stressful as [ __ ]
that is that's why you never put the
fish tank on top of the car
um yeah we we definitely didn't do that
but putting him in the car doesn't help
either
i mean you moved cross country too from
florida yeah but it's by myself
like i think i had one parent with me to
help me out in like a
buddy system but it was just my [ __ ]
well you think you had one parent buddy
i had one you know this is how he speaks
this is how you communicate
you just have to figure it out i think
my way through and then you have to
figure out if it was a fact or not
i just like that when he talks tiff is
smoking cigarettes
i've never seen casey really stress even
though he has it in his body like he
stresses [ __ ]
he internalizes yeah but then like what
i like about casey is it doesn't bother
me
that's why because he internalizes
bothersome so then like he's stressing
he'll externalize the right people
though so if me and
me and casey were to move like he'd
probably like be in chaos in his heart
but i wouldn't feel that [ __ ] so the
whole time i'm like this is a great
experience man we're moving out
great but it's two different experiences
i think that's awesome
and you're like hey casey don't forget
to get that chair too man just pick that
one up too and pick that up
oh this is so easy nice yeah i wonder
why i'm stressed
i like hanging with my friend accurate
accurate
case is very good with the flow yeah for
sure uh so
adam out of moving though like the
entire process of moving
what is the most stressful part for you
guys is it the packing
or like finding a mover budgeting saving
up
packing sucks right yeah that's what
this survey said too
yeah packing was the most stressful part
of you i really liked about moving is it
forced me to throw away a lot of [ __ ]
that was the second most stressful thing
which is sorting out what to keep and
what to get rid of
you just gotta murray condo though right
should be like thank you yeah bye
but to figure out if you if you want to
let it go like the pro
the part before that three months later
when you start unpacking everything and
you're like oh i finally moved in i
guess i shouldn't pack these boxes
you're like oh [ __ ] did i throw that
[ __ ] out
three months to unpack we still have
boxes that doesn't count because that's
for the office which isn't done yet but
like
exactly the whole house is unpacked
oh yeah it's true but that's my point
dude my mother is a hoarder and she
marie condos by going
she's like thank you oh i need you still
okay putting you back
she's like you're welcome you're welcome
genuinely damn
you think your parents will go on the
show hoarders so that's probably why it
was so crazy when
we were moving you just had to move
everything you didn't throw away nothing
nothing bro you kept the fish
they still have a frozen ice block of
fish she couldn't even give the fish
away to our neighbors
wow and they wanted it i don't know if
it was like that but
we could have they had room do you guys
get stressed out from moving
i get stressed out i mean i think it's
stressful but i don't think is that
stressful as like
working like first day at a job or
something or breaking up like that
or having a baby or having a having
children yeah yeah
whoever said divorce that i mean i've
never been through a divorce of all i'm
saying it's like that must be
less okay then moving one percent don't
you have to move when you get a divorce
though
yeah oh true it's built into the divorce
so why not
yeah so i guess that's kind of counts do
you think it's because people have a lot
of stuff
like a lot of stuff to move maybe i
think moving out sucks but moving in is
fun
i'll cut you off but it's okay oh really
yeah why
yeah moving in is super fun you have a
new space you could like
visualize how you're going to live in
that creative it's like sex moving out
it's not as fun as moving in
so when you pull out it's not as fun as
pushing it i feel you my friend i feel
you
i definitely okay that's where the
pleasure is when you push in push in you
go ah
it's oh yeah the way where we had to
think and process and figure it out
um i'm glad we explained it thoroughly
yeah i think i think we are able to
visualize it very thoroughly
when you eat a popsicle it is better
than moving out
just kidding everything is yes um
i forgot what i was going to say sorry
no it's okay
what is the most stressful situation for
any of you guys oh that's what i was
gonna
say like moving aside or whatever like
just what is like running away from a
stalker that's pretty stressful yeah
does that happen to you you had a
stalker you had to run away not a
stalker but
running away from someone who was armed
and
uh didn't like my friend that's scary
i've never been in that situation i
think that's why
things that are normally stressful my
bar
for the world and what i expect out of
humans is so low
that like if something happens that's
stressful
i'm not that stressed out what about
like non-danger involving stress oh yeah
yeah there we go then i don't really
think it's stressful well like for
example if
if if everyone wants to go to a
restaurant or something downtown
la i'm like [ __ ] that i'm probably out
so true parking oh parking in downtown
uh stresses me the [ __ ]
parking is making a left turn making
left turns in high traffic areas really
high traffic areas that's just because
you gotta look both ways
i'm just saying we went from like like
death stalker to like
traffic signals because we have said
non-binary yeah no
i thought we were going to go to
something like we were like really
stressed i was like finishing my taxes
always like it's
really stressful but like the left turn
down to i'm like i
i can handle a left well no because then
there's like pedestrians
it worries him okay again i'm not taking
anything away i just know you it was
just a very
you know the intersection is actually
the worst to make a left turn
really stressful is the most stressful
is getting second place
[Laughter]
what kind of attack was that he's like
taking the left turn that's interesting
and you're like what the [ __ ]
i'll kill you don't mess with the white
[ __ ] claws will come out
wow you're liking the fire yeah you
haven't seen that fire
[Music]
you